Mia and I have Angela McDonald here also
who's co-hosting we're going to be
talking about procrastination and thank
you very much for muting yourselves
right now but this is a participatory
thing so you can show your video if you
like and you can share as well so one of
the first things I wanted to ask is
everybody came here because I'm guessing
that procrastination is something that
you experience so could you raise your
hand if you feel like you've experienced
procrastination before or experiencing
it right now even do we know how to
raise our hands this is a good question
Angela
where does if they hover over there I
see if you hover over your names you can
raise your hand or lower your hand so
thank you for sharing that I can't see
everybody's hands right now but thank
you for sharing that and now I'm seeing
some video now as well what a lot of
yeses in the chat box a lot of yeses in
the chat box okay well where we all fall
victim to this at different times and
I'm sorry the video I just messed up a
little bit my question to you is I'm
gonna answer it for myself but I'm gonna
ask you as well what is the thing that
you find that you procrastinate most
about and if you can write that in the
chat box and this the picture will come
up again sorry that it went away Angela
are we back up yes the beginning picture
thank you yes we are and and Andre can
you see the chat can you see what's
coming into the chat I can't okay that's
fine I'll let you know kind of what's he
coming in okay that would that would be
great okay let me see maybe I can see it
up here sorry everybody this is my first
time doing a webinar on this system and
so angela is kindly offered to assist
and help me make sure that it runs okay
so I anyway my name is Andre amia and
I'm flailing around here a little bit I
have been a coach for about seven years
now
and worked at UNC Chapel Hills Business
School for quite a while working on
leadership and and also coaching
executive coaching for people in the MBA
program and I've worked in Japan for a
while and the Netherlands and several
other countries making films actually
that was that was my other life was
making films which sometimes I still
indulge in
so procrastination has been something
that has kind of fascinated me and I see
it as a aspect of learning and have done
research on how we learn and also on
procrastination and tried and true ways
of being able to overcome
procrastination so the first thing I
wanted to talk about is actually
learning and that if we are we are more
successful if we are engaged in the
process of learning we're aware of how
we learn best and that there are
different ways to learn what they found
in studies is that the more where you
are of learning and of the the process
of learning and thinking about learning
the more successful you'll be as a
learner so being able to take that step
back and looking at yourself and looking
at how you do things will actually make
you a better learner as well so we'll
talk about a couple of strategies with
regard to that as well so on today's
agenda we're going to talk about
learning to learn a few things about
that and I would like you all to
participate in any and all of this by
the way okay what is a habit I'll be
asking about that we'll be sharing with
the group a bit directly about that and
then we're going to talk about it's very
specific ways that you can overcome
procrastination and one of the most
important things to keep in mind when
I'm starting to say this is that this is
not one-size-fits-all
you're gonna take things that are going
to be useful for you and leave behind
the things that are not useful and in
developing a plan to combat
procrastination or to be a better
learner both okay this is about making
some conscious goals about what you want
to do and then adjusting along the way
none of us are perfect
none of us there's no expectation of
that the plans that we set out we change
and we see what works for ourselves so
do you keep that in mind that if this is
not about developing one plan and if it
does
work you're screwed this is about
looking at yourself as a learner and
figuring out what works best for you
trying these things out and leaving
behind the things that don't work and
trying others so I wanted to give that
as a general overview
[Music]
so
oops sorry so that was it sorry my
individual solutions learning breaking
it down and changing changing being the
most difficult things and we'll talk
about habits and how we have habits and
how breaking habits is a difficult thing
to do but the key to which is changing
what the process is before you get to
the reward and being conscious of the
reward that you're working towards any
questions so far
first of all about what we're going to
be talking about today and you can
either speak up or you can write in the
chat room and aundrea this is Angela
I'll let you know a little bit of what's
happening in the chat since you can't
see it when you asked about what they
procrastinate on I should say we not
they we all do all of us I'm not
excluding myself
it's definitely there's a lot of talk
about planning for study time and when
something's really hard and they're not
sure how to tackle it and there's a lot
of all the above and people are looking
forward to hearing your advice okay
great
okay so let's move on
one second learning how to learn this is
something I want to to ask you first of
all our are you all aware of how you
best learn the answer you could give me
could be I'm a visual learner I'm an
aural learner meaning I through the
hearing I like with visual I like
doodling that's that's what gets it in
my system there's those are two
possibilities I learn only when I'm by
myself
or I learn best in a group those are
that's another possibility do you have
some sense of already what your best
practices in learning and retaining and
[Music]
when you've been the thing to think
about is when I have been successful in
past of retaining information that I'm
trying to learn what did I do to do that
so for me for example I tended when I
was in high school
cram cram things in at the last moment I
would do well on tests
I would retain very little so I could
get all A's on everything that I crammed
in at the last moment but the things I
retained the most so the things I
learned the best were things that I
actually kept approaching in different
ways so I'm not sure what people have
shared because I cannot see the chat
right now but I'm wondering what what
people are sharing at this point I'll
see if I can see the chat I don't think
so I'll give a little update and again
feel free anyone to unmute yourself and
speak up and talk yeah a lot of visual
learners and and interesting a lot of
people who like to learn by themselves
okay I think I'm the exact opposite I
feel like I I I like talking about I
like rehashing it and talking about it
in five different ways for it to really
sink in than to just sit and try to
learn right this
best when I can talk to others for
things like language I learned visually
current learning currently learning
Chinese and it's easier for me to learn
the characters versus hearing it I
understand that mm-hmm
it's also a very visual language that
makes a lot of sense what I've written
down here is a couple of things devices
that you can keep in mind when you are
challenged learning wise one is creating
visual cues for yourself and visual it
means a lot of different things so it
can be breaking things down into I'm
trying to memorize a phrase like that
that phrase the the Mark Twain quote
that I gave you your eat your frogs in
the morning which I'm sure you're
wondering what that means eat your frogs
first so if I'm trying to remember what
eat your frogs first is e Y F f ey F F
might be said 'if might be something
that I can remember easier that's like
how we for example you probably memorize
the names of the planets that way when
you were in grade school and memorizing
the names of planets they give a visual
sort of way to do that giving it other
names things that are easier for you to
remember but there's other things about
the visual that can help with our
learning which is where you are when
you're learning something physically
where you are you might for example
learn best when you're in your bedroom
it's good though for you to move to
other spaces to learn the materials that
you're learning in another space as well
what that does is it reinforces what
you've been learning so that you don't
associate it just with the space that
you normally study in but that you
associate it with other spaces as well
it becomes a deeper learning that way
does that make sense to everybody
you'll let me know by a yes or so in the
chatroom yes yes yes lots of yeses okay
because what this is this we're playing
with the brain and we're playing with
ways that the brain retains information
and if you are thinking about something
and trying to study thing in different
locations it gets it into the brain in a
deeper way basically so if everything
you study is in one location one set of
lighting one one one let's say what's
one color even
it limits it limits how well it's going
into your system or how deep it is or
how long you're going to retain it so
the more that you can think about these
things that you're studying in different
locations with different visual stimuli
that can help you retain retain more as
well so that's why I'm saying about
learning different places the other
thing is to move they've shown in
repeated exercises that exercise moving
around shaking up the brain getting some
oxygen in there that also helps you
retain information much better it also
gives you the opportunity through moving
and through sleep of having a different
of having a break basically they found
in one study and I have this at the end
of the presentation that if you have
better sleep and you actually have a
good night's sleep your ability to
perform is that much higher as far as
learning itself ghosts being able to
retain information being able to make
connections that your brain can take
this in basically and make something of
it whatever it is that you're studying
so moving sleep learning in different
locations and having in creating visual
and aural stimuli to remind you of what
it is that you are what are you're
trying to learn depending on what your
focus is
and I said oral oral could be music
literally that you're singing song in
things that you have a rhythm to have on
how to memorize things that will stay
longer if you're an aural person
basically any questions about that to
start with
anyway there are a couple questions okay
and I know a couple people said they're
in places where they can't they can't
they can listen at the can't speak
so um a good question here is how often
should a break be especially when
they're studying they're really
interested we are totally gonna get into
that and and some of this is totally
based on science although you may be
individual so give me give me a second
and we'll get to that next any other
questions
how much is enough sleep someone's
asking if four hours is enough and
someone else is suggesting eight hours
okay so there's a good friend of mine
who's a very famous editor actually who
has lit yeah I think he's 75 76 now he
lives on four hours of sleep and he's
not sacrificing it for himself or
anything this is how he functions best
in life they say that eight hours of
sleep is necessary you need enough sleep
that you wake up rested
so the answer is not one that I can give
you that you need six and a half hours
and you need eight hours and you you
need nine hours okay that I can't give
you but it it is about being rested and
so that is about getting good sleep as
well some people have problems falling
asleep some people have problems staying
asleep some people have problems waking
up groggy basically from their sleep and
not feeling like they got enough a lot
of this goes to good sleep hygiene and
having a routine before you go to sleep
in order to fall asleep well in order to
stay asleep that's a big subject but I
will just say that the answer is not
that I can give you a number that's
something that you do have to discover
for yourself best and make sure that
it's not about the number of hours but
that you wake up with rest and that your
brain has actually been able to take a
break any other questions
any advice for night owls the person
concentrates better at night but has to
wake up early the next day I think
that's very difficult if you have to
wake up early the next day I know people
who they function best at 2:00 in the
morning and they have structured their
lives so that they do not have to be
anywhere till 11:00 in the morning they
you know that is one way to do it if not
you're gonna be living in sleep
deprivation all the time if you're up
until the middle of the night and you
have to wake up at 6:00 in the morning
that's a problem so I don't have any
great strategies other than if you know
that best about yourself and you know
that that's something you cannot ingest
you need to figure out how to adjust
other things about how you're running
your life
and so we switch subjects often or study
one topic for a long period it depends
on the subject that we're talking about
but generally the best idea is to switch
things that you were working this
actually goes to the time issue okay so
let that with the time issue as well
okay I just want to to make sure we get
all of that into that one any other
questions I think a couple others are
gonna be related to your time as well so
how about we go let you continue this
was just the cute quote that goes to one
of the the essential things about now
we're going to talk about
procrastinations and wait us to deal
with it and this will touch on the time
issue
this quote is cute but it's actually
serious eat a live frog first thing in
the morning and nothing worse will
happen to you the rest of the day the
idea behind this is whatever it is
that's sitting in your way that is the
most annoying and the most frustrating
and the thing you don't want to do the
thing they'd like I'll do anything else
I'll clean the house before I do this
that's the thing to tackle first that's
not the thing to leave to the end of the
day that's the thing to do first so that
you have a sense of accomplishment first
of all and the thing that you keep
avoiding is the thing that you look at
first now you may not finish it because
you may hate this thing I don't know
what this thing is okay but it may be a
subject that you're not in particularly
into but the idea is to schedule it
first thing not to put it off and to get
beyond it as fast as you can
and Angela totally interrupt me if
people have questions or want to
contribute something yeah I think
there's everyone's sounding very
interested I'm getting some nice
comments so I think that again and if
you want to make sure I ask your
question please I'm there and yeah okay
so we're actually gonna do a little
share your thoughts thing right now and
this is to set up you thinking about
what some habits that you're in but
first I want to talk about him this can
be a small goal or a bigger goal but if
you could share a few people or
everybody um share what is the goal that
you have in mind maybe the goal that you
have in mind in taking a Udacity course
you can focus it on that if you like but
I'd like you to give some thought for a
moment to what is your goal so wish I
could see the chat
Andre if he's if you maybe hover down on
the bottom it might allow you to mine is
next to my share button
sometimes when you present it does kind
of move away yeah let me look and see
yeah yeah Oh aha
can you see it yes wonderful this is
happiness is starting to be mine
although I've been looking at I and who
else two of you I've been able to see
your pictures this whole time and so
I've been actually talking to you I okay
and you all are able to see the chat as
well is that right yeah it looks like
everyone can see it I see them because
there's been some responses back and
forth yeah okay great
the market okay these are great great
goals everybody has okay let's let's
move on so keep that in mind that goal
if I had a piece of paper I'd have you
write it down um we're gonna talk a
little bit about what habit is so you
see this lovely picture that I have here
the habit Luke Mac and I want to explain
this a little bit to you so there's two
three aspects here the cue the routine
and the reward we're going to spend more
time talking about what the reward is
but I'll give you an example of what I
am talking about here okay so the cue is
that I need it the cue is more like a
trigger basically so the trigger is I
need to study Dutch because I know
enough Dutch that I should be able to
speak better but I don't really like
studying it so I want to learn Dutch oh
you know what I want to do now I want to
eat something because I'm trying to
avoid studying Dutch and I am now going
to reward myself by eating something
and because I feel feel better that way
so I'm looking for what AM what I'm
looking to identify is what is the
trigger what is the thing that I'm it's
annoying me that is that puts me puts me
in to not studying anymore basically is
the annoyance of I don't really want to
I don't really want to study Dutch maybe
I don't really feel comfortable with it
I feel kind of incompetent with it and I
feel down on myself because I haven't
done it okay my routine is I'm going to
avoid it and I'm gonna avoid it by going
into the kitchen and I'm going to grab
something to eat and my reward is oh my
god I feel so much better now my stomach
is full I my brain feels calm ok now
I'll go back and sit down and try to
study my Dutch again oh oh I want to
avoid studying Dutch and I go into the
same routine a bit again basically what
we're looking for when you change a
habit is the habit that you the thing
that you go to we want to change how you
get there so actually I'm not being very
articulate there let me try this again
the reward that I was going for is that
I wanted to feel calm and I wanted to
feel a bit supported basically and then
I could start studying Dutch again the
routine was I went to the kitchen to eat
that's the habit that I want to change I
don't want to go to the kitchen to eat
because it's sort of a false sense of
security but I do want the reward of I
want to feel secure enough and calm
enough that when I study I can be
focused basically and keep moving
forward on my goal so a question I would
have for you is what is the routine
that you can sometimes get into so
something triggers you and you go into
routine another routine of mine I'll
just share with you cleaning the house I
will clean the refrigerator rather than
do a task that I want to do I don't know
if any of you do that sort of craziness
but I will clean things rather than
rather than do the task in front of me
because I'm just avoiding it and the
reward that I get is I actually
accomplished something that stuff needed
to be clean I feel better for about it
so you can come to my house and
procrastinate oh yes by the way that's
all in my own home okay I actually clean
but that's one of my weird routines that
I get into so a question that that I
would have for you is to think about it
this is something that you can share
write down yourself or share in the chat
but think about the tasks that you put
in front of yourself that are
challenging and what you start doing
instead and what is the feeling that you
get out of doing that thing instead
the thing that we'd want to change with
a habit is look it's good then I clean
my house that's a wonderful thing that's
not a good habit to get into as far as
study it goes it just you know just like
eating is not necessarily good habit for
that but figuring out what the filling
is that I want to have that reward
feeling that I can have and working
towards that in a positive manner that
is something that I want to do one of
the things that I like doing and I'll
just give this as a as a an idea for
everybody is I like having candles lit I
look at a reward sometimes a little
reward and we'll get to this time
management thing also this is part of it
is finding rewards that we can give
ourselves that we work towards so I like
lighting candles I won't like candles
until I feel like I have I have worked
towards that to light the candle and
enjoy that maybe you like having tea and
maybe you couldn't replace ice cream
with tea and work towards that something
that's a little healthier something that
gives you a little more boost then let's
say the ice cream of this picture
so the question is the queue or the
thing that might trigger you basically
especially with regard to focused on
studying right now and learning that
what comes up for you when you start to
sit down to learn that might trigger you
or mites basically set you off course
this can be a very personal thing so it
may not be something you want to share
in the chat but you are welcome to it
could be emotions around this the
subject matter
it could be feelings around competence
or incompetence around certain subject
matters and not others
it could be honestly it could be noise
in the room
you know like simple things like I am
NOT in a quiet space and I can't think
and therefore I'm gonna go do all these
other things
think about for you what it is that can
trigger you to lose your focus focus and
set you into a spiral of now I need to
go eat or I'm giving my examples you
have your own examples okay eat or clean
the refrigerator
hmm
I was that virani
that's a good one every distraction out
there on the Internet as as something
mm-hmm
okay Adrian you bring up something that
that we will touch on a little bit but I
thought I'd touch on it now to begin
with but all this input that we're
getting from social media from just
looking at your email from what's
happening in the news right now these
are all wonderful distractions that we
go to that we think we're doing things
with and are exactly the things that we
need to shut down and at the beginning
when we are going to be studying and use
as a reward
as opposed to the distraction itself so
you work towards the reward fear of
missing out now
okay
thank you for sharing these things and I
think if you're looking in the chat and
other people's thoughts you may be able
to identify some aware of your own and
also realize that we have a lot of us
have the same challenges
yeah this hole this hole you know how
many things can we focus on it once
basically makes it hard to do anything
at all
and it seems like that's what a lot of
people are falling into thinking of
failure
it's that daunting task in front of
yourself that's one of the things that
we'll talk about one of the ways to
break that down and start making smaller
increments that we're focused on
okay let's move on a little bit Oh what
happened here
do you see anything Angela
I just see a pretty background so dank
and purple oh I don't know what that was
about
okay so now I'd like you to think about
how you reward yourself so you know it's
funny some of some of your triggers I'm
going to say could be your rewards
eventually you're looking for fun things
on YouTube could be a reward for me
lighting a candle can be a reward I
other ideas going outside and getting
some fresh air is reward some of these
are very small some of these are much
larger but I'd like you to actually
really think about what are the tiny
rewards that I can give myself for
staying focused what they found is that
with regard to procrastination and
everything in life that we
subconsciously or consciously work
towards our rewards we don't work
towards our torture
we don't want to punish ourselves so the
more that we can say this is a reward
that I want or that I I would like to do
and work towards that timing was the
better off we are
you may love studying studying may be
your reward
studying may not be everybody's reward
during a book that's cool meditation is
an excellent one
you
hmm so studying things that is not for
university studying anything else may be
the reward
great to have a list for yourself of
what your go-to rewards are and and
thinking about them consciously
as things that you want to do after
after you've studied basically so that
you're walking a thought nap excellent
okay so now what we're going to do is
discuss seven strategies to get us
through procrastination and this lovely
tomato timer over here has a lot to do
with the timing that we're going to talk
about so the end and by the way some of
these may be totally obvious to you and
some of these may be the first time
you're hearing about them or thinking
about them okay so this is seven ideas
that you can incorporate some of them
not all of them and mix and match
basically the idea is to come up with a
plan
trying some of these strategies and then
let's assume the plan fails that's okay
then it's coming up with another plan as
to how it's going to work part of it is
being engaged in your life and in the
way you think and in the way you succeed
and to be able to stand back from it and
find out what actually works best for
you okay so I'm going to give you ideas
and these are all good ideas they may
not be all the good idea for you okay so
the first one smaller challenges
especially for people who start to go
into the dred area of my life is gonna
be a failure if I don't finish this
class
okay giving that as an example or I'm a
failure for even having taken this class
because I should have learned this
before where your mind may go to these
very extreme places where it doesn't
help you to be there and the idea with
smaller challenges is don't put in front
of yourself either your life's goal or
even the courses goal but break down
what the small things are that you want
to achieve during this study session or
during that you want to achieve during
some time period basically that you
might be procrastinating from make the
challenge as small as you can make it it
may be I am just going to read this
chapter without judgment I'm going to
get through this chapter and figure out
what I need what I need to take away
from it make the challenge as small as
you possibly can some people work with a
planner journal planner journal is
something I worked with a lot in high
school ice to be like okay I have an
hour for math I have an hour for history
I have an hour for this and that's my
three hours and this is how it's gonna
break down and I thought it was really
cute like graphing it and stuff like
that
now I feel lucky when I have all my
appointments in my book and I actually
go to them I I'm not very good at having
a planner journal but this works
amazingly well for some people really
planning out their days or their study
time what you're planning on doing
during that study time for example what
it is you want to achieve this goes back
to the smaller challenges but some
people work really well with the planner
Journal the idea is with both of these
and and with many of the things that I'm
bringing up is start to have a plan and
make the plan not a big thing but a
small thing
so timer so you see this tomato timer
here the Pomodoro timer there's a gentle
a professor who came up with this idea
and has tested it and it has to do with
how long can we concentrate for and
actually be focused and actually retain
information what he came up with was
that the average person can only retain
information for about 25 minutes now you
the meaning sitting down and studying
for 25 minutes before they need to take
a break they need to go do something
else they need to think about something
else they need to breathe they need to
meditate they need you to light a candle
the idea of the Pomodoro timer which is
just the name of that timer that he
happened to use there and I've put a
link to these different timers that you
can get online is that you set a timer
for the amount 25 minutes let's say okay
you maybe you have a little ad D you
can't sit for 25 minutes
that's fine figure out if it's 15
minutes that you can sit for this is not
about sitting for two hours straight I'm
really good at that I can actually focus
for a pretty long time
25 minutes might be a little short for
me but regardless I've done it with 25
minutes the idea here is that you are
setting a timer starting it when you
start whatever task it is that you want
to do and you know by the time that
timer goes off you are stopping doing
that task and you're going to reward
yourself with something
now you can reward yourself with
something small at a 25 minute timer if
you are studying for two hours and
breaking it into 25-minute segments at
the end of the two hours you may have a
bigger reward you're working for so if
at every 25 minutes you have a small
reward like light a candle have a cup of
tea stand up and stretch and do yoga
stretches look look everybody with
social media I'm going to look on social
media but I'm timing it out for only 5
minutes before I get back to work those
are the small sort of 5-minute rewards
you're looking for and then at the end
of the two hours you get a bigger reward
maybe the bigger reward is I'm gonna
take a nap maybe the bigger reward is I
am gonna really look on social media and
respond to everybody who's been chatting
with me for the last two hours that I
have been incommunicado you figure out
what your bigger reward is also so given
a plan of I'm going to study for two
hours you should have three breaks in
the middle of them small breaks and then
a larger break at the end all of those
breaks you should they should be
something that you are looking forward
to
what I find with the 25 minutes also
which is kind of fascinating is
no matter what you're trying to do if
you know exactly how much time you'd
need to do it or you have to do it not
what you need to do you have to do it
most often that is what you're able to
accomplish in that time you work faster
you're more focused and you whatever it
is you set out to accomplish you can
generally accomplish during that time
it's amazing how many things we think
about when we are unfocused that
distract us what I've written down here
is savor happiness this is the rewards
we're talking about this is about really
working towards that five minute reward
of going and walking around the block or
playing a game
enjoy it this is something that you've
earned
having a dance party I love that so once
that's a perfect sort of that's a
perfect sort of small reward by the way
the three to four minutes dance dancing
in the room it's exactly the right
amount of time gets your brain going to
someplace else entirely gets you moving
and then you can sit back down again and
you can plan like what is the music I'm
gonna go listen to
anybody have any questions about these
and about the Pomodoro timer
this is one of the most effective things
for dealing with procrastination by the
way
no questions okay
relax and enjoy and learn to trust the
system so these two things are a little
different from each other
and it's sometimes easier to tell people
to relax or tell people to stop worrying
than it is to do it but the amount of
energy that you put into worrying and to
being tense about things takes away from
what it is that you're focused on so
finding ways to set the task small
enough so that you can accomplish them
and that you can relax about it as
you're doing it is actually very
important the more agitated you are the
less likely it is that you're going to
finish tasks
bata training for workouts yeah
yeah that's it that's a that's a good
point I think Adrienne made that this is
a little like tabata where you have very
intense hit workout basically and then
and then you have to take a break
interesting how our brains and our
bodies can function similarly to each
other as we evolve learning to trust the
system so part of this is that leap of
faith that leap of faith that if you do
some of these things and if you have a
plan and you do them that they can work
so that's what the the learn to trust
the system is as I said you're gonna
have a different system that I'm gonna
have and Mehmet Daren is gonna have a
very different system than kako ruto
okay
you're just going and I hope I'm saying
your names right but you're gonna have
very different thing you're gonna have
very different systems from each other
but you have to try to start to trust
that they will work and actually
incorporate them
not keep questioning yourself and the
last thing about this is to develop a
new plan this may not work for everybody
like your plan you may have gone okay
great Andre I said do this I'm setting
out the entire plan I'm gonna be doing
it perfectly tomorrow and it didn't work
for you it didn't work for you because
you got a phone call in the middle of
the thing and then you got totally
distracted and you got into that phone
call and the 25 minutes timer went off
you ignored it you continued with the
phone call you didn't get back to things
that plan did not work okay maybe you
should have turned off the phone during
that time period
that might have made that work better
for you maybe putting you the phone in
another room and that you're going to
ignore it you have to figure out like
what's gonna be standing in your way for
accomplishing these plans but then also
figuring out a different plan if it
doesn't work for you a lot of mothers
have and fathers who work from home have
children in the home how are you gonna
figure out how to be able to be
responsive to them and also have time to
focus maybe it means you're studying at
night maybe it means that you set them
up with a game before you study and say
hey I'm gonna need 25 minutes before we
visit with each other again who knows
they respond to that or not but it's
about figuring out what the triggers are
that start to pull you away from
whatever it is your goal is
a few that reminds you to use the
Pomodoro I would actually every time
that you sit down to study put a
Pomodoro timer up on your your machine
as well
you can bookmark it and you can think
okay it's time to study let me put a
timer up thank God I have only 25
minutes I have to focus and what am I
going to do for fun afterwards I'm just
responding to Jonathan Gerald's question
so these cues can be it's time to study
that could be that could be your cue for
that you could also make it your
homepage as a reminder maybe somebody
else has it has a an answer for that
also an idea of how to cue yourself to
even start Angela did if you have any
ideas I'm I'm open
well I'll tell you I actually like you
know we use so many of us now use timers
on our phone but I kind of like the idea
of a big obnoxious red tomato on my desk
I think it'd be hard to miss so I think
you know a silly timer like that could
be a really good thing because it's a
little more physical a little more like
you know you can touch it feel it stick
it there and it's not your phone sitting
there again that can cause distractions
as a distraction right someone up above
also asked about the 50 minute 50
minutes or not and as I said I am I am
actually I can sit for quite a while and
study when I have the focus I would be
better where I'm better working with the
timer because it makes me work faster in
a sense and more concentrated and less
distractible but your timing might be
that like I really feel like I get my
groove for 20 minutes and I wanted
another good 15 minutes of focus or 20
minutes of focus before I stop so that's
you know fifth and it's works for you
and it really works for you great set
your timer at 50 minutes when they've
done studies before they finding that 25
minutes is about all that most people
can tolerate before they're want mine
starts to wander and they start to want
to do other things and so we're trying
to capitalize upon that
[Music]
so the college semesters and online
courses that seems to me to be an an
excellent opportunity for the planner
journal because this is a larger issue
Aditya Banach brought up which is okay I
need to organize my whole life you know
but all of these things basically going
on not a study session not one class
that I'm trying to not study for but all
of it and I would say planner journal is
probably one of the best things for you
to start thinking about but also not
freaking out so setting it setting those
smaller goals in front of yourself each
day is important I'm not sure if that
answers your question idea but it's what
I would start thinking about
any other questions that I missed that
we should talk about a little bit
you
this just gives you some of the people
that I've referenced basically in this
to I guess you can review basically if
you want to read more about it and this
is more of a question and answers answer
time so Angela is are there any I'm
gonna just open up the chat bigger so I
can see
[Music]
any other questions anybody has and that
have not been answered so far I have a
question what is the best way to avoid
or stop procrastination so I've just
presented a few different ways for you
to avoid or stop procrastination so
we've talked about timers we've talked
about setting small goals we've talked
about having a journal we've talked
about having a goal in mind to begin
with basically I and then and and
smaller goals within that that you want
to accomplish and one of the major
things is recognizing what your triggers
are what your response to the trigger is
to get your reward basically and seeing
if you can stop some of the things that
are triggering you away from whatever it
is you want to focus on so for example
if social media is one of the things
that is totally a distraction for you
use it as a reward not as a distraction
shut it all down when you want to focus
on study don't give yourself that
opportunity just start flailing around
have a timer know that this is during
this time these twenty five minutes this
is all I'm doing
so working towards reward I hope that
answers your question Michael
okay any other questions anybody has do
you feel like you have some new tools
now at your disposal to try to combat
this problem that we all have oh by the
way Michael I didn't mention the one
other one that I started with which was
eat your frogs the first thing in the
morning whatever is most distasteful for
you start with that
so this seminar will be up online I
don't know exactly what the timing of it
will be but it will be up online and
available for you to visit again and to
take down notes you are quite welcome
everybody okay YouTube page thank you
thank you everybody for joining this
seminar today it's one I've never given
as a webinar before so I appreciate you
being poller --nt while i messed up
technology wise and Angela helped me out
here
I thank Angela McDonald for being a
co-host with me and helping me run this
session I wish you all the best of luck
and I also hope that you find rewards
that you work towards that will really
help you see through your goals thank
you thank you I think it was fabulous
and I've been taking notes myself so
thank you I quite welcome
let's see how he's done bye everyone bye
bye